[Music]
hello and welcome back to another
episode of what's up roff hi martin
hello froff
how are you doing finding you alter i am
doing okay
i'm doing okay because i can see the
progress of history
which means that hopefully
this
calamity on this planet will come to an
end soon i'm with you on that let's ask
god to bless this discussion
our heavenly father
we are here once again to ask your
blessing on this discussion please
we need you we need the holy spirit to
guide our discussion
and we need it now in jesus name amen
amen
you've titled this one a limit to god's
forbearance
now we've been talking a lot over the
years
about
the necessity to prepare
for the events that have been portrayed
in prophecy
[Music]
one of the things that one should
seriously consider if god opens the ways
to get out of the cities
because there will be such turmoil in
the cities
and the trade unions will be one of the
means to bring about a time of trouble
such as never was
now trade includes many things
it doesn't only
include workers rights
it includes transport
it com it includes
food preparation industry
it includes the whole infrastructure
that is necessary to make an economy
work because at every level
there are people working that are part
of the trade unions that's it
so we can expect
some serious issues in the near future
and then there's this economic
discontent in the world
now in this discussion we're going to
look at
what is happening in the world at the
moment just to bring us back into
perspective
but the issues that we really have to
look at is how god's people should
prepare for the times that we are living
in
yes because this is all just going to
get worse it's going to get worse and
and we don't want to be just a news
broadcaster
that says this is what's happening in
the world and that's what's happening in
the world we want to say how does it
relate to prophecy and what does that
mean for our personal preparation
so it's important that we
we don't neglect
serious
bible study that's
100 we it's even more
serious and necessary now to do that
than to watch the news yes
so what is this about a limit to god's
forbearance well let's open with
testimonies for the church volume 5
which says with unerring accuracy
the infinite one still keeps an account
with all nations
while his mercy is tendered with calls
to repentance
this account will remain open
and when the figures reach a certain
amount which god has fixed the ministry
of his wrath commences they can't
disclose
divine patience ceases there's no more
pleading of mercy
in their behalf
now when i look at some of the
legislation that's coming out in the
world and some of the actions and some
of the riots and
all of these issues going on in the
world
and what they are based on
are they based on the principles of god
or are they based on
absolutely the opposite yeah absolutely
the opposite it's actually
turning into chaos at this stage yes and
the moral decay is so blatant
that even the most hardened person will
have to realize that there's something
seriously wrong with the world
so the time is coming when in their
fraud and insolence men will reach a
point that the lord will not permit them
to pass and they will learn that there
is a limit to the forbearance of jehovah
now the very last thing that will happen
is to make of none affect the authority
of god yeah and since the authority of
god is
intricately inseparably linked
to the fourth commandment because that's
the one that says he has the authority
therefore it is a test
and people have you know complained and
said this is not the case it cannot be
the case but it has to be the case
and it has to be lost
because when you take away the authority
then god will have to act exactly so the
devil will try and postpone that action
to the last minute and that gives people
a false sense of security it'll never
happen
and what is also happening is it won't
be as
forthcoming as you think it is it's
always via a backdoor it will be in
darkness as one of the spirit of
prophecy
statements tell us
so that's why we have to keep our eyes
open because
most of the world will in any case do
this
thinking they're doing god a favor yes
absolutely
now is an interesting
interview that church militant had
with the lady who's part of congress
yeah
and it's very fascinating what she has
to say i mean she sits in
this
great body of people that is supposed to
determine the direction of a nation the
laws of the nation and the
implementation thereof
so this is a very serious issue of
course we must understand
that church militant is a
ultra conservative catholic organization
that
probably believes that pope francis is
more of an anti-pope than a pope
but nevertheless it's interesting what
they perceive and how they think
i'm michael voris the political world
and the religious slash spiritual world
have become almost indistinguishable
from one another which is not really
that surprising when you consider the
stakes what do you have to say to
i mean you've just described a situation
with america falling apart
and you hear all these religious leaders
like oh we have to love the family and
this and that is uh is that two-faced
it's interesting i thought we had a
separation of church and state
right
no it's a it's a what it is is that
satan's controlling the church
that the church is not doing its job and
it's not adhering to the teachings of
christ and it's not adhering to what the
word of god says we're supposed to do
and how we're supposed to live
and what they're doing by saying oh we
have to love these people and take
care of these migrants and love one
another this is loving one another yes
we are supposed to love one another but
their definition of what love one
another means
uh means destroying our laws
it means uh
completely perverting what our
constitution says
it means
taking unreal advantage of the american
taxpayer
and it means
pushing a globalist policy
on the american people and forcing
america to become something that we are
not supposed to be loving one another
means
is is the true meaning of loving one
another and loving others means
that you also have to uphold the law you
have to uphold the rules
and
and you say no there's times you say no
so if the bishops were reading the bible
and and truly
um
preaching the word of god
to their to their flock
and not covering up sex abuse and not
covering up child sex abuse and
pedophilia
yes that that would be
loving one another would have the true
meaning and uh not the not the
perversion and the twisted lie that
they're making it to be
you're
obviously you know concerned about the
whole spirituality
aspect of this you know this is satan
people's faith
what do you
how do you gauge the
spiritual
character
of the united states right now
i don't even know why god has not
destroyed us
when satan sells a lie and a sin
it's not loud it's whispered softly and
gently into your ears and into your soul
and he tells you it's okay
and he says it's just just this one
thing
you're just gonna get it done get it
over with and then he tells you a
promise
he promises you
all these dreams that that you have in
your heart
and that's how satan sells a sin
that was a very interesting
snippet of an interview with marjorie
taylor-green congress woman
lady
and
her comments
are fascinating
now it's interesting that the
interviewer who comes from the
conservative catholic
viewpoint
states that
the political world and the religious
world are inseparable
now we've said for a long time that the
image of the beast has been forming
and
people you know seem to be reticent to
accept that
but it's so blatantly obvious
and
not only the interviewer
but also the congress lady
agrees
that they are working in unison
and
ignoring the law
in terms of the constitution
when asked what her spiritual
idea is in regarding the united states
she says she's surprised that god hasn't
destroyed them yet
i mean they pass laws
that you can terminate a pregnancy
still on the final day of the pregnancy
and she thought that these kinds of laws
would never be passed but they were
passed with a comfortable majority
so it seems as if the moral
barometer
has really dropped to levels that nobody
could imagine
and there are some people who claim
that calamities will come and the spirit
of prophecy tells us that calamities
will come yes
and it will be said that these
calamities are vials of the wrath of god
that is being poured out
precisely because of because of the way
in which the political world is acting
in unison with the religious world
my personal view is that we are in a
pendulum swing situation once again yes
and that the pendulum has swung to
extreme liberality
and one or two major calamities and the
pendulum will swing to the other side
and then the very thing that we have
predicted for years will come to
fruition
everything is being prepared for it
behind the scenes the legislations that
have come in
the messages that are being sent by the
leadership and by the church
it cannot be otherwise no and the
sequence of how things happen
it's
almost
unbelievable to say that it's haphazard
yes and
if you look at the sequence in the past
two years
you have this then you have got the next
and next and everything seems to just
happen all of a sudden to build up this
and each one changes legislation a
little bit the game it's no longer
emergency rule it is built into the
general
laws so
this has been planned modern for a long
long time and there's a master
strategist behind it whether we want to
believe it or not
and
liberal activists threaten supreme court
justices after that leaked document
regarding the reversal of
the abortion
debacle laws
and it's fascinating that the media is
constantly portraying this while other
things are happening in the background
so people are focusing over here
while unbeknown to them things are
happening over here it's true like one
of the things that we can mention for
instance is once while this is keeping
you busy laws are being implemented that
were like you just mentioned previously
under national disaster yes it wasn't
ensconced in law yet
and it removes your personal freedom
and your freedom of choice we've had the
same happen in our country
our national disaster
has lapsed they've
but all the laws are still going on
because they've been introduced in
another way
so let's have a look at these
videos on liberal activists threaten
supreme court justices
[Applause]
[Music]
if abortions aren't safe then you aren't
either that's just part of the message
outside wisconsin family action here and
it continues inside the building what
you're seeing around me right now this
isn't the answer to anything also
written in debris and glass in her
office wisconsin family action president
julian appling says the message is clear
it's precipitated by
the leaked supreme court opinion right i
mean it's obvious madison police say it
appears someone threw a molotov cocktail
inside the building
respect us
we
[Music]
to take care of peace
don't you dare tell me i'm embarrassing
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm killing
[Music]
the christian rights decades-long push
to revoke abortion rights is just part
of their broader agenda well what else
what else do they want what else is at
stake this is not just about abortion uh
this is about a much broader uh set of
issues uh that are have that really are
about a kind of white christian right
worldview it's very important for us to
recognize that it is christian extremism
that is at the root of the shame and the
stigma that allows laws like this to
pass that allows justices like this to
be confirmed discovered that they could
manufacture and then channel their moral
outrage toward abortion creating a new
litmus test for conservative politicians
references to god and christian beliefs
are often invoked in these political
instances with some saying outright that
they believe america is a christian
nation
so martin do you think america qualifies
as a christian nation i think there are
christians in america that still stand
for moral values
but as a legislation and country
um i don't i think it's
exactly where
satan wants it to go well
we are back to as it was in the days of
life
this whole debate
about abortion this whole debate about
gender
if you are rooted in the bible
then all of that
falls away
if you think of the women
in the bible
but their greatest desire
was to have
children and if they didn't have
children in old testament times they
felt forlorn
and they mourned
and there are so many examples
and god often used
the barren woman as a symbol of his
church
but also as a symbol of the promise that
the messiah would come
and
if you look at the creation account
when god formed man
he formed him out of the dust of the
earth
he didn't speak him into existence
he didn't speak him into existence like
the rest of creation
he formed him
he lovingly formed them into
a male and a female there was nothing in
between
and
the bible makes all these things very
clear
and the sanctity of life
is ensconced in the biblical narrative
you have the value of life
how valuable is a human life so valuable
that god decided he should die for one
exactly and if there was just one
he would have died for that one
that's the value
you read psalms 8 what is man but about
mindful of him
you know
you have this depiction that man is but
a worm
but that's not how it should be read
it should be read what is man
that you are so mindful of him
what do you see in him that you are
worth
that you are willing to die for him so
the value of human life is
indescribable
and
and that's also what's happening now
the value of another human being
is if you look at this video that we've
just looked
where do you see
value
for another person's life in this it's
also showing me
or it makes me think
if you put us in the prophetic picture
when the
dragon is wrath with a remnant of a seed
and they will go after the commandment
keeping people
this is what it's going to look like but
martin the deception runs so deep and
this is what people have to
take cognizance of
there are people that have values
christian values in the united states in
other nations as well
but particularly in the united states
you have the bible belt you have you
know this this
great
depth of christian values
and there will be an outrage
when christians think about what is
happening in the world
so that when calamities should come
they will easily be swayed to say these
are the judgments of god for what is
happening in the world
but what is the solution back to moral
values yes whose moral values
theirs
not god's the catholic conservative
movement we have to get back to moral
values and that includes the catholic
version of the ten commandments exactly
that's what makes it so
deceitful sometimes because that
morality that you have when you watch a
video like we've just shown
is
you want to
side with the side that says yes we have
to sort this out we have to get morality
back yes but then you can also stand on
the wrong side you fall into that next
trap it's such a terrible deception
so
besides the moral issue let's not go
deeply into you know whether this is
right or whether that is right anybody
who has even a very limited idea of what
the scriptures have to say will realize
that the world is in a deep state of
disease yes
and the important thing like we just
mentioned to remember
is that
the christian moral value
will take over
but then like you've mentioned it will
be the catholic
one that's
reigning supreme
it's interesting that this lady
particularly had this interview with the
conservative arm
of the roman catholic church
but there are other issues which are
facing us which are also of course
biblical and will be drawn back into the
whole
scenario eventually
now this besides the moral decline
and the political mileage
that the powers that be will get out of
the moral decline
we also have the issue of famine
threatening famine
and here the world bank warns about food
security
many countries are facing growing levels
of food insecurity reversing years of
development gains
and threatening the achievement of
sustainable development goals by 2030.
now martin who was responsible for
reversing
the
capacity to produce food and to
distribute food well this war that's
raining in russia to that together with
covet and the supply lines being removed
it seems
improbable that these are just
events that take place without any
planning whatsoever because it's so
orchestrated it is so universal it is so
so
smooth in its action
that it's difficult to think that it's
not planned and it plays so well into
their hands if into the scenario yes
exactly if you want a great reset then
that is exactly what needs to happen
as of may 5 2022
the agricultural price index is up 41
compared to january 2021
mason wheat prices are 54 and 60 percent
higher respectively compared to january
according to the world bank's april 2022
commodity market outlook the war in
ukraine has altered global patterns of
trade production and consumption in ways
that will keep prices
at historically high levels through the
end of 2024
exacerbating food insecurity and
inflation
one crisis in ukraine and the whole
world
is suddenly lame
do you buy that no it doesn't make sense
because what about the other wars that
happened and this never happened before
over the coming months a major challenge
will be access to fertilizers which may
impact food production across many crops
in different regions
fertilizer prices surged in march up
nearly 20
since january 2022 and almost three
times higher compared to a year ago
now we've said for a long long time
that we need to grow our own vegetables
and we've spoken about the necessity of
organic farming
we don't need all of these fertilizers
and these are not things that happen
overnight no you have to work at it you
have to
you know implement it you have to
experiment you have to see how this
works you have to improve your soil
and all of these issues
that is why it is important that people
listen
to what we have been admonished to do
get out and start implementing these
things
and if you can't get out there are
alternatives yes
you have to start preparing you know
i've heard
some people sent us messages
now
when the sunday law comes in
then we have to start
looking after ourselves
well
then it will be
last events will be rapid ones you need
some time for preparation you know if
you're stuck in the city at least get a
hold of a lot of seeds so that you can
grow some micro greens
and
do a little bit of preparing store some
things which which will last like dried
beans and grains and things like that
one has to start looking at the world
and saying there are serious things
happening
the other thing that is happening is
that the food processing plants
in the world
are
seemingly under attack
and they say these are you know
accidents that happen by chance but they
are so regular
and they target such specific industries
that it is likely that some of this is
orchestrated as well well even if you
want to go the route of saying no this
is not
the outcome is the same it's the same
because this is heading
for a trouble yes and
even if if man has nothing to do with it
demonic forces behind the scenes
do have something to do with it so let's
have a look at this little compilation
eastern oregon where crews are battling
a major fire at a potato chip processing
plant air 12 flew over the scene at
shearer's foods on highway 207 in
hermiston we're told the fire was caused
by an explosion of a portable boiler
there
two people were taken to the hospital
there is a fascinating common
denominator which is that all of these
dangerous episodes happened at plants or
facilities that process or store food
and of course with inflation food
shortages supply chain problems and the
war in ukraine the timing here could not
be worse we should note that over the
past several years major incidents at
food plants have happened on a fairly
regular basis but it is the recent and
dramatic increase in frequency that
really caught our eye and in the span of
just one week during the safest point in
aviation history we also had two planes
that crashed into food plants
well i think the video speaks for itself
what do you think yeah
so let's just look at this little list
here as to what's been happening just in
2022 and you have all the dates here
and you can see there
we're talking about april
going back to
august 9
and most of it here is in 2022
on this list and the food plants that
were
targeted or that experienced these
problems
here they are a whole list of them
and
they're quite substantial
and in different states as well yes
they're all over the all over the united
states locations or in oregon in idaho
in arizona
etc right across the board and what was
the main reason fire
airplane crash
explosions
and this could be pure chance martin
but it could also be
a planned action to bring about
a time of trouble such as never was like
you mentioned before
the bible mentions famines
how it
came to a famine doesn't really matter
no because either way if this was
orchestrated or not the outcome is the
same now imagine if you had a crop
failure
and the crop failure could be blamed on
a lack of fertilizer and can be blamed
on ukraine russian
and then
the nice big one climate change and
climate change because this is where it
all
links together we'll be getting to that
well then it could be very interesting
so let's look at climate change see how
that fits in here's an article in the
guardian
northern ireland faces loss of 1 million
sheep and cattle to meet climate targets
northern ireland will need to lose more
than one million sheep and cattle
to meet its newly
legally binding climate emission targets
according to an industry commissioned
analysis
seen by the guardian the large-scale
reduction in farm animals comes after
the passing of the jurisdiction's first
ever climate act
requiring the farming sector to reach
net zero carbon emission by 2050
and reduce methane emissions by almost
50 percent over the same period
now it's well known that
when cattle and herbivores in general
and ruminants in particular
that's all your clean animals like sheep
and goats and cattle
when they digest their foods byproduct
is methane production and there is a
vast amount of methane that is produced
in this fashion
so they will have to reduce that and the
way to do that is to get rid of the
animals
now some may say that that would seem to
indicate that we have to go the
vegetarian route
but that means all of these farmers must
be redirected into alternative
farming
and once you've done all that then you
have to basically become proficient in
what you are doing and you have to do it
very quickly
so
before the the changeover takes place
you can have serious effects on food
production definitely this is not just i
mean if you take a normal farm
changing and one farm over to
something like this a zero emission form
it's not going to be cheap no and it's
not going to happen overnight either and
it won't the
success of it is also not guaranteed no
so separate analysis by the uk
government's climate advisor suggests
chicken numbers would also need to be
cut by 5 million
by 2035.
both the pig and poultry sectors in
northern ireland have seen rapid growth
in the past decade so this is where
we're heading they're going to
change the entire agricultural sector
but
you must remember that big corporations
have bought up the farmland like bill
gates is one of the largest farm owners
in the world
vast tracts
and
they have the capacity to do exactly
what they want they could let it life
fallow what then exactly
if you take countries like southern
africa where you had many farms that
were land claimed they just went back to
being
what they were before with no production
or zero production on them
so these are all very interesting things
that are happening in the world
worldwide that's it and what happened
also is a lot of the countries that were
producing
started getting
reliant on imports but if a country
itself can't produce enough anymore it's
not going to export to those countries
that import it are going to sit with a
big problem as well
and then of course you have the constant
threat of
more epidemics
this is like a bible script being read
all over again in the news media
there will be famines
there will be moral decay
and there will be pestilences
so bill gate warns of a more fatal covet
variant calls for global surveillance
aren't you grateful that we have these
people that are so of a and he's been
rather silent of late because he was
writing a book right he's been writing a
book lately on pandemics
i'll make sure that i don't buy it
because i have better things to read
like like this good book over here
and i need to prepare for
what the bible says is coming to the
world but you know let the gentleman
write his books it keeps him busy
and he's talking about the world was not
ready for the inevitable next pandemic
and that viruses not war pose the
greatest risk of global catastrophe
you know what i've been living quite a
few years on this planet and all of a
sudden
there are so many viral catastrophes
going around that one would believe that
it's always been like that
i'm sure the young generation is so
conditioned already they think it's
normal yes and especially i think the
generation the younger generations are
very much indoctrinated at this stage
and
fearful
yes for what is about to come
so he called for renewed efforts for
greater investments in global
surveillance of viruses
which has been paused by a number of
countries in the wake of decline in
covet cases so let's have more
legislation let's have more surveillance
surveillance this word this word you we
have to look at
and remember whether you are rich or
whether you are poor
or whether you are of high standing or
whether you are of a lower standing
you will have to comply to the mark of
the beast
nobody
will be exempt
do you need
ultra
effective surveillance in order to do
that definitely are they implementing it
well let's have a look may 3
2022 cdc
tracked millions of phones to see if
americans followed covert lockdown
orders
so are they doing it they are doing it
and once again
how do we have to look at this
just about the news article and what
they're doing no we have to look at it
in terms of the prophetic picture so who
is this going to target eventually
and this is the cdc
so this is not some alternative media
i wonder whether we should fax check the
cdc oh just a reminder on that
when you put
in pro food processing plants disasters
just those words
go and see the first page is fact
checkers
then you must start worrying yes because
the facts check us we know where they
come from newly released documents
showed the cdc plan to use phone
location data to monitor schools and
churches isn't that interesting martin
and wanted to use the data for many
non-covet 19 purposes to
location data information on a device's
location sourced from the phone
which can then show where a person lives
works where they went
the sort of data the cdc bought
was
aggregated meaning it was designed to
follow trends that emerged from
movements of groups of people
but researchers have repeatedly raised
concerns with how location data can be
de-anonymized
and used to track specific people
now we're getting there
what according to the bible
is that group
or who belongs to that group
that will be specifically targeted the
commandment keeping people
those who keep the commandments of god
and hold to the testimony of jesus now
you see
they won't be the only ones
targeted no there will be others as well
but this all will come to that point
if you qualify for that
part of keeping the commandments all
right now we've we've said all along
that
the social credit system that the
chinese have introduced
is something that is alive and well and
coming to your city soon and your
country
is christianity daily
and it says social credit scoring system
designed to modify behavior launched in
italy
well they always start
you know gently in one nation then it
goes to the next and the next
it is a given according to the
scriptures that this will take place
we don't even have to read this article
because you know they're going to link
it to your pocket smart citizen wallet
when you do certain things you get
certain incentives
but remember
this is done
for climate change
and what is pope francis's la dout to
see
encyclical ensconced what's ensconced in
there
for climate change sunday legislation so
this is tracking tracing with
surveillance yes and now it's linked to
a social credit system for climate
change so just look out all of this is
being
linked together
people think that when you say sunday
legislation
that you're on some religious bandwagon
and
some of the talk show hosts have said
that's never going to happen
well
they are like ostriches because it's
happening all over it's particularly
prominent even in non-christian
countries
but you know maybe we shouldn't call it
sunday legislation
maybe we should just say legislation
making of non-effect the authority of
god yeah
that's a very good point that's the way
we should see it and that's exactly what
they're going to do and they're going to
watch your behavior
because certain people will have to be
targeted you see the easy way to
implement these things is using climate
change because that word
everybody is sensitive to it if you
understand they okay i understand this
for climate change so it's for a good
it's for common good for the common good
and of course the climate change
will be linked to a common day of rest
and that's the thing because they've
already introduced that the sunday
arrest
because of climate change so you have a
car free sunday in many countries so
it's coming sort of and you see the
problem is
that even if you are a commanding
keeping person
it can look okay to you to do all these
things yes you might actually go along
with it
so here's an article from writers the
heat is on italy plans to turn down air
conditioning to save energy
italians could face a long hot summer
with the air conditioning turned down in
public offices and buildings as the
government seeks to reduce its reliance
on russian gas supplies
so you bring in the war you bring in the
climate change issue and it's all
leading in a particular direction
air conditioning systems will be set to
keep the temperatures no lower than a
balmy 25 to 27 celsius
during the warmest months of the year
according to an amendment to a
government decree
on energy usage in the winter rooms will
not be heated beyond a maximum of 19 to
21 celsius under rules due to come into
force
from the start of may to the end of next
march
so whether they're using any pretext
whether it is a war
in the ukraine
whether it is climate change
people are channeled into different
modes of lifestyle
and they will have to
ramp up their rhetoric
so that eventually they will have to
have work free days
in order to save energy
that's it
and which days will that be martin
there's only one there's only one
definitely won't work on any other day
than sunday no
there is cnn politics doj announces new
offers to enforce laws around climate
crisis
toxic pollution
garland said the oeg will serve as the
central hub for our efforts to advance
our comprehensive environmental justice
enforcement strategy
they have such nice
sounding titles to their strategies
with the office working alongside a
number of other
intra-departmental agencies including
the civil rights division and the united
states attorney's offices to prioritize
meaningful and constructive engagement
with the communities most affected by
environmental crime and injustice
civil rights division isn't that
unions
absolutely
so
legislation and unions
for climate change yes but look how they
link crime and injustice to this as well
so they're making a sort of small ghost
board with all of these parameters
included that's the thing
the one that they actually want to do is
here but not to make it so obvious you
in sconce it with all the rest of all
this injustice because
you would look like a buffoon if you say
it's
not immoral to have people drink
sewage water
yes but now you bring climate change in
with it
very very clever
here's an article in the verge watch a
swarm of drones
autonomously track a human through a
dense forest
their surveillance is so sophisticated
these days it's like
something out of a movie
you see
10 20 years ago you had these things
these drones
type of technology no it's it's a
reality it's a reality
so if you're living somewhere tucked
away in a forest they can still come and
get you right these things are as big as
your palm
and some of them are smaller some of
them are the sizes of insect yeah
and they can sneak in through
cracks in the doorways
so the group of ten palm-sized drones
communicate with one another to stay in
formation sharing data collected by
on-board depth-sensing cameras to map
their surroundings
if one drone loses sight of the target
others are able to pick up the trail
and the capability to navigate cluttered
environments for example is desirable
for a range of military purposes
including
for urban warfare
schwarz tells the verge
as is the ability to follow a human here
i can see how this converges with
projects that seek to develop lethal
drone capabilities that minimize risk to
underground soldiers in urban
environments
weiner said in the 1960s that there is a
disastrous focus and obsession with
know-how
which tends to eclipse the moral
question we should be asking what is it
good for
so the fact that they have
the capability
is a good indication that they want to
use it and there's always
the nice part
they want to use it for disaster relief
finding people that
lost
and now
you must always think what we've just
mentioned
what is the outcome where are we heading
now
we have no intention to be
fear-mongering no in any way
because if you have the lord on your
side i don't care what technology they
throw at you
it would be totally meaningless if god
wants to prevent their usage he will
so let's have a look how this thing
works
[Music]
[Applause]
so martin basically you have nowhere to
hide right yeah so surveillance we've
mentioned that is what they want to
implement for
looking after climate change and all of
this so do you think they will use some
of this technology in this
so when the bible says
that everyone great and small
rich and poor
will have to make this decision
there's nobody that can hide no
so how's that possible well they have
the technology to find you no matter
where you are so whether you like it or
not you have to make a decision
and the decision is who is your
moral authority
and if you've made the decision that god
is your moral authority
you will be in
opposition
to the law
that's it that's what's going to happen
so how far is this going and how is it
being implemented now
martin you included an interesting slide
here on climate and sustainability
summits run us through this one well it
was just interesting to me that
the counting bodies in south africa
which i was part of when i previously
worked i'm still part of them so i get
updates and so on
and in south africa this sustainability
on climate change it is a big thing it's
written into our law and now there's
summits
it's just i just put it in to show that
everybody is on board with this
climate agenda
it is like a tentacle that has gone
right across the globe
it's not just a
a feature that people are just talking
about this is actually being implemented
on a universal scale that's it and it's
going to affect everybody
even if you are
a salaried person or you are a main
business this is already affecting
everybody so the laws will eventually go
to what
pope francis wants it to go to and what
is permitted on certain days and what is
not permitted on other days
now here's an interesting video about
china
and of course they're starting
with
zero covert
but what if they want to
test for other things like zero carbon
emission
or
compliance to whatever they want to
introduce let's see how far this
technology has taken us
now to china where none of the citizens
have the power of choice
unless you are xi jinping
in which case you get to do pretty much
what you want whether it works or not
the chinese president's word is the law
he has issued a new dictate to his
officials
he wants a crackdown on those who
question his zero covet policy
health authorities are now resorting to
extreme measures
this is one of the testing centers in
china
here one of the citizens was pinned down
to the ground she was forced to take a
wuhan virus test
[Music]
such tests are now mandatory in all
hotspots those who refuse are subjected
to force
chinese health officials are barging
into homes to hunt down violators
even the elderly are not spared like
this woman
she was pushed out of her home to take a
test
who issued these draconian orders
the instructions come from the top
despite its obvious failures chinese
president xi jinping is not ready to
give up on zero covet
now he wants officials to crack down on
those who question it
recently xi jinping shared a meeting of
the politburo standing committee
this is the top decision-making body in
china
the chinese president had a clear
message for them those who question
distort or reject zirokovid should be
punished
xi jinping faces a massive public outcry
the lockdowns have led to a backlash
the city of shanghai rebel last month
hundreds of residents banged their pots
and pans in protests
china's policies have taken a toll on
its citizens going by xi jinping's
message their misery may not end anytime
soon
now
anybody living in the west will be
appalled when they see something like
this right
but
i i would suggest they look back in
history
and what happened in the middle ages
when the church of rome had full sway
if you didn't comply
then you were treated far worse than
than what the chinese are doing now far
worse you were placed into
custody you were tortured have you ever
been to those museums where they show
the torture instruments that were used
in the middle ages i mean tower of
london yes it's horrendous
even if you then take
not so long ago
some western countries implemented
similar
draconian
yes rules for people that didn't want to
do some things and even in the time of
franco in spain they still used those
instruments of torture that the
inquisition used
now people are often duped into thinking
that the communist regime is actually
against
religion or against catholicism
but we should remind the listeners that
communism was perfected by the jesuits
in their reductions in south america
and that the countries that we are
talking about are actually
running
on jesuit principles yes
so it's interesting when you read for
example
that the bbc reported here that hong
kong cardinal joseph zen was arrested
under china's security law
and the hong kong police told the bbc
that the group was suspected of
appealing to foreign countries or
organizations to impose sanctions on
hong kong
and threatening china's national
security
arresting a 90-year-old cardinal for his
peaceful activities has to be shocking
new love for hong kong illustrating the
city's free fall in human rights in the
past two years
so human rights watch said the vatican
is concerned about the cardinals arrest
spokeman matteo bruni
said in a statement scores of
pro-democracy activists and protesters
in hong kong
have been arrested under the national
security laws since it was imposed by
china
in 2020
so what it appears like is that the
chinese government is being very harsh
to even the religious bodies and it's
been kept under the garb for national
security yes
now
this is something that creates sympathy
with the church right
and this is a 90 year old gentleman that
was here
arrested
what is the real position of the roman
catholic church with regards to china's
policies
well here's the catholic register
february 6 2018
which spells it out quite clearly it's
quite a while ago but this is what
they're saying
china is a model of catholic social
teaching protector of human dignity
bishop says
the chancellor of the pontifical academy
of social sciences has said that china
is exercising global moral leadership
in the principles of catholic social
teaching and defense of human dignity
in an interview with the vatican insider
he recently said that at this moment
those who best realize the social
doctrine of the church
are the chinese
what do you say to that i don't know how
they bring these two together what we've
just watched in that video and also
and
people might say okay yeah but this is
now and that was then
it was the same in 2018 why were the
jesuits created
to destroy protestantism and they wanted
to go back to the middle ages where the
church had total control over humanity
that's right
if you didn't comply
you were whisked off and you ended up in
some dungeon
and
if you didn't change your mind
and recant you were tortured and
even tortured to death
and they used the state to do it for
them so that they sanctimoniously could
say
that it wasn't them
but it was according to their laws
now let's go to the communist countries
what did the kgb do they did exactly the
same and that's what i if you take
social doctrine is common good
china says
they did it for their own national
security for their common good and
people have to comply to whatever it is
they say who's pulling the strings
behind the scenes i think we can fairly
confidently say
might be coming to a city near you yes
so what else did he say surrounded told
vatican insider
that he had recently visited china where
he says he found that they the chinese
seek the common good subordinate things
to the general good
the common good you better comply you
may have no opinion of your own
to be subject to the roman pontiff is
altogether necessary for salvation she
claimed in the middle ages
well we've had articles where
jesuits have longed for the good old bad
old days to return you remember that
the bishop said that the people's
republic of china has defended the
dignity of the human person
and in the area of climate change is
assuming a moral leadership that others
have abandoned
he criticized the united states where he
said the economy dominates politics
liberal thought
has liquidated the concept of the common
good
they do not even want to take it into
account it affirms that it is an empty
idea without any interest on the other
hand he said the chinese propose
work and the common good
so they are a model
of
catholic social
doctrine
and where does that emanate from
from
the school masters of the world
namely
the jesuits
it is surprising to me
that protestants even from our own
denomination
are proud when they study at
institutions
that the jesuits have raised up even
georgetown university
how if we look at the history
can we
marry the attitude and the social
teaching of this institution that has
caused so much bloodshed over the over
the years and over the centuries and
over the millennia
how can we incorporate that
into
our
moral parameters today
so just to make sure that people
understand where this is all leading
let's just put in a few slides
to show
how they're going to link
the sunday
and we said not the sunday the moral
authority of god versus the moral
authority of the church how they're
going to link it to all of this
is the business insider
of 18 march 2020 world agency suggests
lowering speed limit by 10 kilometers
per hour and car free sundays to save
oil
working from home up to three days a
week
where possible and car free sundays in
cities
rounded out the iea's top three ideas
it's interesting
that they would have this as their top
three
car free sundays such action can reduce
the short-term use of
380 000 barrels per day of oil if
implemented in large cities every sunday
the amount drops to 95 if cities only
instituted a plan for once a month
car free sundays were introduced in
countries such as switzerland
netherlands west germany during the 1973
oil crisis car-free sundays help support
the uptake of walking and cycling which
can generate a positive spillover effect
throughout the week so this is how they
introduce it via the back door yeah and
when i read something like that and they
say they did it in 1973 oil crisis it
rings to me they tested it if it will
work
then and now they want to start
implement it on a worldwide basis
but let's make sure that this is where
they're heading this is what the pope
said in 2013. pope francis has a few
words in support of leisure
responding to the question do we need to
rediscover the meaning of leisure
pope francis replied together with the
culture of work there must be a culture
of leisure as gratification
to put it another way people who work
must take the time to relax to be with
the families to enjoy themselves read
listen to music play sport
but this is being destroyed in the large
part by the elimination of the sabbath
rest day more and more people work on
sundays as a consequence of the
competitiveness imposed by a consumer
society
in such cases he concludes work ends up
dehumanizing
people again of course he confuses
sabbath with sunday but
that is the nature of their theology
the idea of a catholic exalting the
sabbath sounds particularly peculiar in
the american context
in the united states catholics were
never the great proponents of
sabbatarianism observing sunday as a
special day for worship or race
i think they are ill-informed
that was a protestant thing
from the moment the puritans arrived
they began enforcing laws to reserve
sunday for church going
over time what came to be called blue
laws covered different activities and
varied by state
over time the official justification for
the laws had changed
but it was still protestants who pushed
for them now martin this is very
interesting
from the beginning protestantism has
been confronted with
the sabbath issue
karlstadt
introduced this idea in the time of
luther
and there was great consternation
and many many protestants
who were at loggerheads regarding this
issue and to this very day you have
groups within the baptists also that
keep the seventh day sabbath the
saturday it's not only the seventh-day
adventists
but as you know
the roman catholics have the law
that sunday is their day of rest right
protestantism has incorporated that into
their creeds
they had an opportunity at the council
of trent
to take the position of sola scriptura
and return to the true sabbath but they
didn't
so protestants made this
sunday sabbath their own but it is a
child of the papacy yes
and the archbishop of reggio plainly
told them
that their their stance on solar
scriptira is false because they adopt
sunday
so this is well known to them in their
history
and then the bible tells us in
revelation chapter 13
that it will be the beast out of the
earth protestant america
that will implement the mark of the
beast and will implement sunday
legislation and that will become
universal
now has it become universal yes it's and
it
that even the history tells you
like this article mentions it's always
been protestants that's
once this
ensconced in law so they're doing the
bidding of the beast
now
it says that the second beast will do it
on behalf of or before
the first beast which is roman
catholicism
so she's been very clever she's taking
this backstage
and it doesn't seem to be her who's
pushing it but here he is openly
advocating for it
and who will do his bidding
the protestants that's it
so about 250 bishops met in rome for a
conference on the movement called the
new evangelization which focuses on
reawakening faith in those already
baptized
one of their conclusions was even though
there is a tension between the christian
sunday and the secular sunday
sunday needs to be recovered in keeping
they wrote with john paul's dies domini
now john paul
wrote this encyclical on ds domini we
very clearly says that the state should
enforce
sunday legislation
and now we saw in china
if they are
a model for this catholic social
doctrine what they say will be okay
to use what how it would look if they
use that force they might not use the
religious aspect no
they will use the climate change aspect
that's it the secular sunday will fall
under climate change correct and they
will receive the mark on their hand
that's it
so martin let's ask ourselves has rome
changed its tune no
the tune is still the same the wording
might be slightly different yes because
they have to soften it a little bit
because there probably has been shows
like ours that are troubling the water
but
so here's catholic news agency from
april
2022 pope francis all countries should
promote family friendly policies
in the previous article we saw he said
that those family friendly
policies were the introduction of sunday
so
family friendly social economic and
cultural policies need to be promoted in
all countries
that's an oblique way
to ask for sunday legislation
he said these include for example
policies that make it possible to
harmonize family and work fiscal
policies that recognize family burdens
and support the educational functions of
families by adopting appropriate
instruments of fiscal equity
policies that welcome life and social
psychological and health services
centered on support for couple and
parental relationships and all of those
buzzwords
have been linked to sunday 100 if you
read the encyclical la doutusi
it has the same wording but it says that
the sunday has to be revered again it
has to be placed back into the center of
society
that's where we're heading
and
this basically gives us
an overview of where we are standing
currently
in terms of the prophetic picture
the mark of the beast will be
implemented
whether we agree with it or not
it will be implemented on every social
level
it will be
universal so you must have a universal
binding force behind it
it will be draconian yes surveillance
will be used they've practiced draconian
methods they are pretty proficient
they're adding the technology in order
to to do this
now is the time for god's people
to spiritually prepare
for what is coming
martin we need to study scripture
we need to
have a change of heart
and it always starts with repent that's
it
and then after repentance we need to
have faith
perfect faith drives out fear fear
that when we have a right standing with
god we need fear nothing that is coming
upon the world
but we need to be aware of what
scripture tells us
when the christians were warned in the
time of christ
that when you see standing in the holy
place the abomination that causes
desolation let the as written in the
prophet daniel let the reader understand
and they did study
and they did understand
and they saw the signs
and they fled to pella
it's time for god's people to be
spiritually prepared for what is coming
so in our next discussion perhaps we
should look at
the spiritual
preparedness aspect
because we don't want to be just a
news organization
god's people need to
get ready
let's pray
heavenly father
prophecy is fulfilling before our eyes
it's working in darkness and people are
so distracted with this that and the
other
but this thread of prophecy runs through
everything
and should warn god's people
as to where we are standing in the
stream of time
help us to be spiritually prepared
is my prayer in jesus name amen amen
[Music]
you